fans are gearing up for the game parking
seems to be on everyone's mind once
again at allegion stadium madison
kimbrough spoke with fans who have
already come up with their own plans to
get to the stadium come game day
ever since allegiant stadium opened up
here in vegas parking has seemed to be
an issue but with recent events and
preseason games things are looking to be
on the up and up
many fans have decided to go with season
parking a pricey but sure way of finding
a spot on game day several lots on and
off allegiance property are available as
well if you aren't one of those who have
season parking getting dropped off is
probably your best bet this way you can
avoid the cost of parking and the walk
making for an easier time arriving at
the gates for entry i'm actually from
oakland so so yeah so i stay at the
hotel at the luxor so i come work on
street i have the option to get parking
tickets but i i'm not driving here from
oakland that's a nine hour drive not
worth it we can take an hour flight a
reminder if you're driving to the
stadium the hacienda bridge will close
at noon on monday for pedestrians
again if you do decide to drive your
best bet is to leave about two and a
half hours early in order to find the
best parking space and make it as easy
as possible to get to the game reporting
from allegiant stadium madison kimbrough
8 news now